à droite sur votre écran les vietnamiens
qui occupent toujours le cambodge à
gauche
la thaïlande en trois points la semaine
dernière le vietnam a fait une incursion
en territoire thaïlandais riposte de
l'armée thaïe que vous voyez sur ces
images des dizaines de morts entre les
deux pincées entre le marteau et
l'enclume le peuple khmer par centaines
de milliers il a fui l'occupation d'état
mienne et le voici campant à la
frontière thaïlandaise repoussé par les
isles deuxième concentration de
cambodgiens exilés ces deux quand vous
voyez en territoire thaïlandais deux
camps dont personne ne peut sortir sac
et aux 25 mille réfugiés
car oui donc 130 mille réfugiés et puis
ceux qui résistent et luttent contre
l'occupation vietnamienne à côté les
khmers rouges de l'autre les khmers
anticommunistes qui vieillissent
parmi eux un personnage étonnant fidèles
soutiens du prince sihanouk le
commandant comme si l'eau à jacques à
bouchard et patrice du tertre ont vécu
avec lui
frileusement groupés autour d'un feu au
petit matin
ces maquisards khmer écoute les
programmes en langue cambodgienne de la
voix de l'amérique
ce sont des nationalistes partisans de
norodom sihanouk leur chef
conques silo à 45 ans est un ancien
officier de marine formés en france
donc si l'eau a défilé vietnamien sur le
terrain il est même le seul des chefs
militaires khmers avoir porté la
guérilla au coeur du cambodge pendant
cinq mois
depuis conques silo à s'est rapproché de
la frontière thaïlandaise de son pc il
commanderait 15 cents hommes armés leur
famille on a cinq kilomètres à peine des
avant-postes vietnamiens loyer nous
avons ouvert le pays depuis le plus dix
jours ils ont toujours eu foi en mai
nous allons former des soldats mais des
soldats homos et des soldats on prend
les petits ce sont des orphelins et ils
seront certainement déchargeant de
liaison des agents de renseignement et
pourraient eux aussi des questions
yahoo
koxie loi vient de marquer un point sans
précédent le 10 juin un chef de
bataillon khmers rouges serei à lui avec
armes et bagages 385 combattants
aguerris qui viennent renforcer les
forces us ianu place en signe de
soumission
les ex leur uniforme contre des tenues
léopard et vous n'avez pas peur que ce
soit comme on dit le loup dans la
bergerie c'est que mer rouge dans vos
unités rien prudemment et rouge sont
actuellement ne sont pas en mesure
d'être méchant brillamment le diamant se
sont pas les routes ou rouge elle si
j'ai beaucoup travaillé pour avoir ce
résultat pour obtenir ces étapes finales
ce ralliement
c'est un travail de longue haleine pas
comme ça
inlassablement dans sa zone d'activité
comme si laura recherché contact avec la
population avec les paysans qui viennent
jusqu'à la frontière thaïlandaise
chercher le rire introuvable à
l'intérieur du cambodge dans les zones
occupées par les vietnamiens
voyez le dieu là c'est pas cette parents
paysans du parlement il est venu de
t'ouvrir de la province de qom centre
frontalier du sud vietnam ça fait ça
fait combien sont ces 500 km de routes
bon ben je veux dire chercher la famille
disparue depuis l'invasion vietnamienne
non il n'a pas pu trouver et il a
retourné encore à sourire
à l'intérieur du cambodge
la circulation est intense dans
l'épaisse forêt tropicale huit à dix
jours de voyage en moyenne pour ces
charrettes attelées sur les pistes
défoncées par les tornades de la mousson
chez cox il aura en charge les sacs de
riz et les semences de concombres de
haricots distribués gratuitement par la
croix rouge internationale
c'est terrible à la ceinture du
vietnamien il faut payer 1,5 en 5 ans
matt ne fâche avec nous encore quelques
paquets de cigarettes
si si la lessive est il faut les ramener
aussi des bombes on verra alors là il
prend la piste
et quand la grande chambre et revel et
cambo et nous sommes sûrs qu'il peut pas
se retourner
ça c'est fait la route au sens unique
donc il a un poste de contrôle
vietnamiens à quelle distance assez de
kilomètres d'ici à ce qu'il aurait dit
si c'est la première ceinture très
dangereuse
pour cela le voyage est encore plus
pénible
aux deux bouts du balancier il y as
jusqu'à 100 kg de riz il faudra porter
sur 100 ou 200 km dans le bourbier
après le péage vietnamien il faudra
encore affronter les bandes de pillards
les bandits de tout poil qui brouille
dans la forêt
comment
break
bon
avec les moyens du bord
le châssis est nous qui essayent de
rétablir un peu de la vie traditionnelle
ce mariage d'un ancien khmer rouge
devant les bonzes rend ainsi valeur de
témoignage
celle d'une renaissance timide du vieux
cambodge
on
quant à ce spectacle de danse organisé
par contre si loi il constituait une
première pour les maquisards les plus
jeunes dans leur pays saccagés ils n'ont
fait que guerroyer
trois jours après cette aimable
divertissement 2000 soldats vietnamiens
se ruaient dans l'assaut obligeant
coccyx lowa et ses guérilleros ce à se
replier dans la forêt après